I want to take up in volume 12, March the 12th 1919, how the earth, the low place, is the image of
one who does not live in the divine will. So the earth is the low place. So Louisa said continuing
in my poor stage, my sweet Jesus came for just a little, and clasping me all to his most holy
heart he told me, my daughter. If the earth were not movable and mountainous, but fixed on all one
plain, that means if it was completely flat, it would enjoy more the benefits of the sun.
For the whole earth, it would be always midday, the heat would be equal at all parts, and therefore
it would produce more fruit. But because it is movable and formed of heights and of depths,
it does not receive the light and the heat of the sun equally. At one point remains in the dark,
while other points receive little of the light of the sun. Many lands become sterile because
of the mountains, because of their height, they prevent the light and the heat of the sun from
penetrating into the depths below. And how many, many more in conveniences.
Now my daughter, I tell you that the earth is the image of the one who does not live in my will.
The human acts render her movable. Weakness, passions, defects form the mountains,
the sunken places in which dens of vices are formed. So their movability causes darkness and
cold for them. And if they enjoy a little bit of light, it is as intervals, because the mountains
of their passions come up against the light. How much misery for one who does not live in my will.
So the Lord has compared the soul who doesn't live in his divine will with the mountainous earth,
which is not able to receive the fullness of the sun all the time. How much misery Jesus
said for one who does not live in my will. On the other hand, for one who does live in my will,
the divine will renders her fixed. That means constant and levels all the mountains of her
passions. Now for that, I want to give you Isaiah chapter 40 verses one to five in which
Isaiah tells us that the mountains must be leveled and the valleys must be filled up in order to form
a highway for our God to cross the desert of our lives into his triumphant reign.
So the divine will renders the soul fixed or constant and it levels all the mountains of the
passions in such a way as to render her all one plane. And the sun of the divine volition therefore
darts through her as it wants. And there's no receptacle in which its light does not shine.
So for a person living in the divine will, the divine light has complete freedom to be able
to work in us and through us. What is the wonder then if the soul becomes holier in one day lived
in my will than in a hundred years lived outside of it. And that really, really needs to be underlined
and emphasized. What is the wonder if the soul becomes holier in one day than in a hundred years
of living outside of the divine will. So March the 14th, 1919, the effects of a suffrage done
in the divine will. So Louisa said she was in her usual state and found herself outside of herself
that is in her out of the body experience and a thought flashed into her mind. Ask about that
thing which you've not told the confessor whether you were obliged to say it and therefore write it
or not. So she said I asked him telling him what the thing was and he said of course you are obliged.
So in her out of the body experience she meets a confessor who is passed on in the kingdom of
God and he tells her absolutely that she has got to say everything because the Lord has been telling
her that since Volume 1 she must write everything and she's most reluctant to write everything.
And then the deceased priest said to her once you did for me a beautiful suffrage if you knew the
good that you did me the refreshment that I felt and the years that I paid off so this man is in
purgatory. And Louisa said I don't remember tell me what it was and I'll repeat it for you and he
said you immersed yourself in the divine will and you took its power and the immensity of its love
and the immense pains of the Son of God and of all the divine qualities. You came over me and
poured them upon me and as you poured them upon me I received the bath of the love that the divine
power contains the bath of the beauty that the divine love contains the bath of the blood of Jesus
and all of the divine qualities. Who can tell the good that you did to me? He said they were all
baths which contained a divine power and immensity repeated for me. He said repeated. So here we're
told exactly how to pray for the souls in purgatory to give them real genuine release.
And Louisa said as the priest was saying this she came back to herself. Now in order to obey
to my highest confusion and repotence I will say the thing that I had neglected to say
and write. I remember that one day my sweet Jesus speaking to me of his most holy will
and of the pains which the divinity made his most holy will suffer in me said.
So this is Jesus speaking. My daughter he said since I have chosen you as the first
one to live in my will I want that you would take part in the pains which my humanity received
from the divinity in my will. So Jesus had said to Louisa that because she was the first
of course after himself and our blessed mother but she was the first one who had been born with
the original sin to live in the divine will that Jesus wanted her to participate in his
interior passion. This is the passion which the divine will made him go through and which
she describes very well in the agony in the garden in the hours of the passion.
So this is Jesus' interior passion. He said I want that you would take part in the pains
which my humanity received from the divinity in my will. Every time you enter into my volition
you will find the pains that the divinity gave me not those which creatures gave me.
So the pains which the divinity gave Jesus are the interior passion those which creatures gave
him is the exterior passion. He said although the pains of the exterior passion were also wanted by
the eternal will but since these were given to me by creatures they were finite and therefore
I want you in my will in which you will find pains in an infinite way and pains that are innumerable.
So once you go into the divine will everything is infinite and immeasurable.
You will have countless nails, multiple crowns of thorns, repeated deaths, pains without end,
all similar to mine in a divine way and immense which will extend in an infinite way to every soul
past, present and future. Now Louisa has been complaining to the Lord since volume 8 that he has
removed the exterior pains from her which she considered absolutely vital to her role as a victim
soul and she found it difficult to adapt to the new way that the Lord was asking of her. Now here
in volume 12 the Lord reveals the new way that he wants her to experience the passion. Up to volume
8 she had been experiencing is exteriorly in other words she had the pains in her body but here it's
all going to be interior it's all going to be in her soul and this is the revelation that the
Lord had made to her that the the pains of the soul are so much greater than the pains of the body
and he's going to give her divine pain and we will become more and more conscious of this
as we go on into the higher volumes. So he said you will have countless nails, multiple crowns of
thorns, repeated deaths, pains without end, all similar to mine and in a divine way and immense
which will extend in an infinite way to all past, present and future. You will be the first one who
not a limited number of times as those who have shared in the wounds of my humanity but as many
times as my divinity made me suffer together with me you will be the little lamb killed by the
hands of the Father. Now so Louisa is being invited to participate in the interior passion of Jesus
she's the only person who has been asked to do this and so she would have a conformity to Jesus
that no other saint ever had because all other saints participated in his external passion that
is the passion that was given to him by human beings but she would participate now in the interior
passion that the Father had inflicted on his Son. So I want to give you Genesis 22 there and the
wonderful story of Abraham representing the Father taking his son Isaac representing the Son
and taking him to Mount Moriah which is a stone's throw by the air from Mount Calvary
and there that he would sacrifice him to the Father and so that is the first
prophetic image of the sacrifice of Jesus and most scripture scholars find it astonishing
that it is the Father who is sacrificing the Son and they don't pick up the full relevance
of the meaning of the Father sacrificing the Son but it's only those in the divine will
will understand it because Jesus says that since our sins were offending an infinite person
our sins were infinite in value and therefore deserved infinite punishment and so only a person
who is infinite could actually repair them and so the interior passion was in fact the most
important one the exterior passion is our participation in this and so again it's our drop of water
in the wine of his redemption. So together with me you will be the little lamb killed by the hands
of the Father to rise again and be killed again over and over again. You will remain crucified with
me by the eternal hands to receive in you the mark of the eternal immense and divine pains.
So I want to give you Galatians 6 17 there the marks on my body are those of Christ.
We will present ourselves together the infinite immeasurable inexplicable humility of Jesus
is something that wipes me out. It wipes me out when you look at the mystery of the incarnation
and all that he did for us but now that he's in glory and he wants us little nothings
to participate with him that's just beyond description it's beyond commentary it's beyond
understanding. It's no wonder the pride of man is such an absolute affront to the humility
of our God. We will present ourselves together he said before the throne of the eternal one.
Well if you go to Revelation 4 and 5 you will find the lamb that had been slain presenting himself
before the throne of the eternal one and being accepted. And if you go to Revelation chapter 12
and the battle that took place in heaven the war between the rebellious angels and the faithful ones
you will find again that it was the sacrificial lamb on Calvary that made all the difference.
Once that was presented before the throne of God so this is what Jesus is asking of Louisa
right here. We will present ourselves together before the throne of the eternal one
with written on our foreheads in indelible characters we want death to give life to our brothers
in other words we want to pay for their salvation with the highest possible imaginable price.
We want pains to free them from the eternal pains isn't it extraordinary?
So I want to give you John 1513 so Louisa is being called to the highest privilege
but the most extraordinary pain. If she thought she had pain before then it's going to be nothing
to what she will have now and Louisa said Jesus I feel too unworthy and I feel that you are making
a big mistake in choosing me she said poor little one therefore mind what you do and so
she's scared you know that he's making a mistake and many of us have thought that the Lord was
making a mistake in choosing us. I thought that as well and I said it to him only to find how
determined he was that if he wants something done he wants it. So Jesus interrupted Louisa
saying to her why do you fear yes yes I minded you for 32 years in bed that in itself is an
incredible miracle that a person would be 32 years in bed without going mad. I minded you for 32
years of bed in which I have kept you I exposed you to many trials and even to death I calculated
everything and besides if I am mistaken it is a mistake of your Jesus which can never harm you
would give you immense good however know that I will have the honor and the glory of the first
soul stigmatized in my will this is unbelievable revelation we have reached an extraordinary point
we the church has many witnesses of souls being stigmatized in their body holding the marks
of the Passion of Jesus but here Louisa is the first to be stigmatized in her in the divine will
absolutely incredible so you need to mark that off as something amazing to remember
so mark the 18th 1919 it is conception Jesus conceived all souls and their pains and their
debts so each one of us has been conceived in his conception Jesus has redone each one of our lives
individually as if nobody else existed but he has done it for everybody else as well
it is mind-boggling to even try and consider so continue in my usual state Louisa said my beloved
Jesus making himself seen drew me into the immensity of his most holy will in which he showed as though
in act his conception in the womb of the celestial mother oh she said what an abyss of love
and Jesus told her daughter of my will come to take part in the first deaths
and in the pains which my little humanity suffered from my divinity in the act of my conception
as I was conceived notice as I was conceived in the very act of being conceived I conceived
all souls past present and future together with me so we start out at the first instant of his
conception with him and so he redeems the first instant of our conception as well
that's a very important point for people who have been born in unusual ways
and what my people might think that God couldn't have allowed it but the conception of each one of
us has been redeemed by Jesus so they were conceived together with me as my own life
and I also conceived all the pains and the deaths which I was to suffer for each one of them
so all the circumstances of our conception have all been taken care of and all our pains and all
our struggles I had to incorporate everything into me the souls the pains and the death which
each one of them was to suffer so Jesus has suffered our death before we experience it
there's no reason why we wouldn't go into an eternity of divine love
so I want to give you Sam 40 verses 6 to 8 and it is quoted in Hebrews 10 verses 5 to 7
that Jesus came deliberately to give his life
I had to incorporate everything into myself souls pains and the death which each one was to suffer
so as to say to the father my father you will no longer look at the creature
but only at me because we are in him and in me he said you will find all you'll find all souls
and you will find that I will satisfy you for every one of them
as many pains as you want I'll give them to you
do you want me to suffer death for each one I will suffer it I accept everything provided
that you give life to everyone that's the position of the victim soul that they will suffer anything
endure anything so that everybody else has life so this is why a divine power and a divine will
were needed in order to give me so many deaths and so many pains and a divine power and a divine will
was needed to make me suffer so because Jesus was incorporating all soul past present and future
into himself to suffer everything for them no human passion could actually cover that only God
himself could cover it and since in my will all souls and all things are present and in act
so not in an abstract or intentional way as some people think but in reality this is a fact
this isn't just some sort of hazy mystical thing it's a reality he said I kept all within me
identified with me and they formed my very life
so if you take one Corinthians chapter 12 from verse 12 the description of the body of Christ
that we're all part of him each one of us is a little cell in his body it's absolutely amazing
they formed my very life in reality I died for each one and I suffered the pains of every single
soul that's Hebrews two nine it's true that in this concurred a miracle of my omnipotence
and the prodigy of my immense volition without my will my humanity could not have found and
embraced all souls nor could it die so many times so I want to give you Isaiah 53 verses 4 to 7
so my little humanity now why would Jesus call his humanity little when he could
conceive all of us in him it is little by comparison with the immensity of the divinity
the immensity of God so anything in the flesh is little by comparison with the immensity of the
divine and he's saying that in the flesh he couldn't have done it without his divine will
and what he's trying to tell us is that in our flesh and on our human level we can do nothing
John 15 5 without me you can do nothing but when when we are fused into the divine will
and we operate on the divine level that's different and that's why he's asking us to go up there
to be able to do great work for him and for souls of course
so it's true that in this concurred a miracle of my omnipotence and the prodigy of the immense
volition of God without my divine will he said my humanity could not have found and embraced all
souls and nor could it die so many times so my little humanity as it was conceived began to suffer
alternations of pains and deaths and all souls swam within me as if inside an immense sea forming
the members of my members the blood of my blood the heart of my heart how many times my mother
taking the first place in my humanity felt my pains and my debts and died together with me
how sweet it was for me to find in the love of my mother this echo of mine
these are profound mysteries in which the human intellect not understanding well gets lost
therefore coming to my will and take part in the debts and the pains which i suffered
as soon as my conception was accomplished and from this you will be able to better understand
so by experiencing it you will understand the words themselves don't give it to you
so but if you go into the christmas novina louisa goes quite deeply into the pains that
jesus suffered in his mother's womb okay so i want to give you look to 35 and matthew 12 47 to 50
louisa said i'm unable to say how but i found myself in the womb of my queen mother so you'll
find this again now in the christmas novina where i could see the infant jesus so very little
but though tiny he contained everything a dart of light flashed from his heart into mine now that's
infused knowledge and as it would penetrate into me i felt myself being given debt and as it would
come out it would bring back life to me so sorry this dart of light is not infused knowledge it's
the divine will excuse me and so the divine will would give her the experience of death and then
bring her back to life as well each touch of that dart produced a most sharp pain such that i felt
myself being on dawn and dying in reality and then with the same touch i felt myself coming to life
again but i don't have the right words to express myself and therefore i'm going to stop here
so all she can manage to tell us is that she did have an experience of this and somehow grasped it
so mark the 20th 1919 the deaths and the pains which the divinity made the humanity of jesus
suffer for each soul were very real so louisa says i felt my poor mind immersed in the pains of my
beloved jesus and since i had been told that it seemed impossible that jesus could suffer so
many deaths and so for so many pains for each one she has to come back and ask jesus now the
people who are saying that to her are the priests who are discussing this because they're the only
ones there and so jesus answers by talking about his interior passion my daughter he said my will
contains the power of everything it's enough that my will just wanted it for it to happen
that's how creation happened fiat that's all if you read the writings of maria val torta
which very much a goal parallel to the writings of louisa picaretta there were the revelations were
given at the same time by jesus the same person and in one case he was revealing the gospel and in
the other he was revealing the new era of the new and divine holiness but you'll find he's using the
same words and the same expressions and you get real insights into louisa's writings by reading
maria for example maria shows jesus coming up to people who are in dire need it could be a leper
it could be somebody in dead spiritually and you'll find that as jesus comes to the person
whether he reaches out his hand or not what he says is i want it i want it and sometimes a very
seldom but there are a couple of times when he says this one too in other words i will die for
this one too but usually it's just simply i want it and here we have him saying to louisa
that it was enough for the divine will to just want it for a thing to happen when jesus wanted
lassarus to come out of the tomb he said lassarus come out if he wanted it it would happen
and if it were not so jesus said then my will would have a limit to its power
and i am without limits i am infinite in all my things and it's because of this that whatever i
want i do he's omnipotent he's infinite he's immense immeasurable i have a how little i am
understood by creatures and therefore i'm not loved i want to give you hosea for six
and proverbs five twenty three you then he said to louisa come into my humanity and i will let you
see and touch with your own hand what i've told you in other words to handle the limitations
of louisa's intellect and understanding he brings her in to have an experience of it
so that that's what she means by touching it with her own hand and once she has an experience of it
the intellect and the understanding settle they're able to accept it and we have to accept her
testimony because we haven't experienced this ourselves so louisa said at that moment i found
myself inside of jesus and from whom the divinity and the eternal will were inseparable naturally
enough and this divine will this divine will by just wanting it created repeated deaths in
numerable pains blows without scourges sharpest pricks without thorns with such an ease that just
as then with one fiat it created billions of stars if he wants it he can do it if he says yes it
comes into being the moment that blessed mother said yes to the divine yes her human fiat to the
divine fiat the incarnation happened there was no there was no lapse of time
it did not take as many fiats for as many stars as the divine will create it just one was enough
yet in spite of this not just one star came out of the light and the others remained in the divine
mind or in the intention but all of them in reality came out and each one had its own light
to adorn our atmosphere in the same way it seemed that in the heaven of his most holy humanity
jesus with its creative fiat in the divine volition created life and death for as many times as it
wanted so if the divine fiat could bring the whole of creation into being by just simply one fiat
well it was exactly the same in producing the interior passion in jesus if the divinity wanted
it that was it the mystery for me is why did the divinity think we were worth it
we who are so ungrateful were described in these writings as hard-hearted
as utterly resisting everything not understanding
refusing to cooperate and yet he would do it for us to be as a great mystery
i know the answer is that he loved us infinitely but to me that doesn't answer it
there's a mystery there why would he go to so much trouble for creatures who were so worthless
after all the name of the first creature that he made was adamah that's the Hebrew word and it
means dust so out of the dust he made this creature it's great mystery
so louisa said finding myself in jesus i found myself at that point when jesus suffered discouraging
from the divine hands by the eternal will merely wanting it so without blows without lashes the
flesh of the humanity of jesus would fall off in pieces deep furrows were formed and in such a
harrowing way in his innermost part the obedience of jesus to that divine volition was such
that his humanity would melt by itself but in such a painful way that it can be said that the
scourging with which creatures gave him were merely a shadow of that what he suffered from the
divine volition he'll get this repeated in the hours of the passion as well and then
by the divine volitions merely wanting it so his humanity would recompose itself so there you have
john 11 lassarus was recomposed simply because the divine volition wanted it
no mystery so it happened that jesus suffered death for every soul and all the rest
and she said i took part in these pains of jesus oh how vividly i understood that the divine volition
can make us die as many times as it wants and it can bring us back to life
oh she said these are unauthorable things these are excesses of love profound mysteries almost
inconceivable to the created mind i felt incapable of coming back to life to the use of the senses
to motion after suffering those pains and my blessed jesus told me daughter of my will
my will gave you those pains and my will gives life back to you also and gives you motion and
everything else i will call you often into my divinity to take part in the many deaths and
the pains which in reality i suffered for each soul this is not some airy fairy thing
sometimes when we say a grace we think we're talking about something nebulous up in the sky
he says this is happening in reality the pains which in reality i suffered for each soul
not as some believe that it was only in my will or that i only intended to give life to others this
is false they do not know the prodigy the love and the power of my will
you who have somehow known the reality of the many deaths suffered for all do not put it in
doubt but love me and be grateful to me for everybody and be ready when my will calls you
so i want to give you Philippians 129 Colossians 124 and Revelation 12 11
so let's go into March 22 1919 all things came out to life from the divine fiat so the divine will
is the source of all life as i was in my usual state louisa said i found myself outside of myself
and i could see all the order of creation things now in this divine will call that's been given to
each one of us and we are being recalled into that order so that everything inside of us
will go back into god's order jesus told me my daughter see what harmony what order
are in all created things and how all of them came out to life from the eternal fiat
so everything cost me one fiat the littlest star just as the rif vulgent and splendid sun
the littlest plant just as the great tree the small insect just as the largest animal
they seem to say among themselves we are noble creatures our origin is the eternal volition
we all have the mark of the supreme fiat on us it's terribly important that our eyes are opened
and that we begin to recognize that it's true that we are distinct and different among ourselves
we have diversity of offers of light of heat but this is nothing our value is the same
our value is the fiat of god our life and preservation are the same it is in the fiat
of the eternal majesty oh how eloquently creation speaks of the power of my will so i want to give you
sam 19 verses 1 to 6 the heavens declare the glory of god
oh how eloquently creation speaks of the power of my will and teachers that from the greatest
thing to the smallest they all have the same value because they have life from the divine volition
so the value of each created thing is the fact that it is something that came out of god himself
in fact a star would say to the sun it's true that you have a lot of light and heat your
office is great your goods are immense the earth almost depends on you so much so that i do nothing
in comparison to you but and that but is very important the fiat of god made it so therefore our
value is equal and the glory that our creator is given to us is fully similar so i want to give you
one krentians 15 verses 39 to 41 there's a very important thing there there's this huge struggle
going on in society between men and women and at the moment we have women rebelling against men
and women saying we're just as good as you we're equal to you we if you can drive a truck we'll
drive a truck if you drive an airplane we'll drive an airplane if you go in a rocket we'll go in a
rocket what are we trying to prove we're not accepting the enormity of the diversity of creation and
we're not accepting that each one has a different function and that each one has its own gifts and
its own responsibilities but we're all equal in the eyes of god because we've all come out of that
eternal volition and we've all been redeemed by the blood of the lamb so i just don't get it what
the women are trying to say it seems that they're not accepting this diversity so in the next paragraph
then jesus goes back as he so very often does to the creation of man then he added in a more
afflicted tone it was not so in creating man you know it's true that his origin is my fear
but this was not enough for me taken by an excessive love i breathed upon him jesus two seven
wanting to infuse into him my very own life this is the value of man
i endowed him with reason not given to other creatures i made him free he gave us free will
not given to other creatures and i constituted him king of all creation that's jennis is 128
but man is ungrateful so how did he respond
amid all creation man alone has rendered himself the sorrow of my heart the clashing note
and then what do i tell you about my crafting in the sanctification of souls
not just one fiat not just one breath do i place it there disposable but my very life my love and
my wisdom yet how many rejections there are how many defeats does my love receive and my daughter
he said sympathize with my heart sorrow and come into my will to substitute for the love of the
whole human family so as to soothe my pierced heart so i want to give you jennis is six three
where we're actually told that god regretted making us jennis is eight twenty one where he said
well i won't do that again i'll try again collashions two two two three collashions two two three
and james one five
so we come into april the seventh 1919 the effects of the divine will and there's also threats of
chastisements continue in my usual state my sweet jesus came all tired in the act of asking for my
help considering that he's divine and that he can do anything by just wanting it then you have this
extraordinary mystery that he comes and he asks us to participate with him in redeeming humanity
the humility of god is beyond our ability to consider it's it's right thing
in our kingdom the kingdom of god the king has his head lower than all the subjects put together
this is no excuse for us at all raising our heads in pride and arrogance
he's too humble for that jesus leaned his head upon mine and he made me feel his pains
each pain that i felt was capable of giving me death but jesus sustained me and gave me the
strength not to die and then he told me my daughter have patience on certain days more than ever
your pains are necessary for me so i told you before that from volume eight she was complaining
that the pain had been taken from her and her sort of victim status had been removed as far as she
thought now she's right back to entering into the pains of the lord but it's on the highest level
at the divine and so she has pain that she couldn't ever have imagined before
these are pains that can give her death at any moment he said on certain days your pains are
necessary to me so that the world made not turn it all into one flame now there's a threat of
nuclear war that the thing could blow up in an instant therefore i want to make you suffer
he said and with the lance that he had in his hand he ripped my heart open i suffered very much but
i felt happy thinking that jesus was sharing his pains with me and pouring himself out with me
so that he could spare the people the imminent and terrible scourges that were going to break
out then after some hours of intense pain jesus spoke to her now i want to first of all give you
hebrews 12/2 for the joy that was set before him he endured the cross despising the shame
i also want to remind you of the story of the bamboo tree
in case you don't know the story of the bamboo tree i'll just give it here very briefly
and that is in the forest the bamboo tree was absolutely magnificent
and all the trees admired the beauty and the wonder of the bamboo tree and the bamboo tree
knew that it was really loved and appreciated by everybody and the bamboo tree loved its creator
as well and when the lord would visit the forest the bamboo tree would tell the lord that
she really loved him and would do anything for him and so on and would bow her wonderful branches
down to the ground to worship and adore him and then the lord came one day and said bamboo
do you really love me and she said yes my lord i really do love you well he said today
i need you uh i my children are in great need uh and i need you to save them and she said whatever
you want he said well what i need to do is cut you down she said cut me down but i'll be dead
he said i thought you said you would do anything for me and she said but he said i thought you loved
me and in great sorrow she said okay and he cut her down and opened up her heart and made a channel
using her and he brought these channels to the rice fields and let the water flow onto the rice
fields so that the rice could grow and his children could live the bamboo didn't realize that in
giving its life it was giving life to everybody else in laying down its life it was giving life to
everybody else and this is what jesus has taught luisa that in laying down her life this is love
out in the world at the lower level people think love is pleasure they think love is
somebody being nice to me they don't realize that it is a movement out from us to give life to others
at any cost to us they don't realize what love is love is tough love is great love is sacrificial
and this whole mystery of being called into the divine will is the mystery of being called into
sacrificial love jesus said come then into my will and take refreshment after all that she'd
been through and let us pray together for poor humanity i don't know she said i found myself in
the immensity of the divine volition in the arms of jesus and he as though in a low voice was speaking
and i repeat it after him i'll give some idea of what he was saying because it's impossible for
me to say everything i remember that in the will of jesus i could see all the thoughts of jesus
and all the good that he had done for us with his intelligence and how all human intelligences
received life from his mind and oh she said what an abuse they made how many offenses
and she said jesus i multiply my thoughts in your will to give to give to each one of your thoughts
a kiss of a divine thought an adoration a recognition of you a reparation a love of divine thoughts
as if another jesus was doing it and this i do in the name of all and for the whole human race
past present and future i intend to compensate even for the intelligences of the lost souls
i want that the glory of all creatures be complete and that no one miss the roll call and what they
do not do i will do in your will to give you divine and complete glory now we know how to pray in the
divine will then looking at me jesus was waiting as if he was looking for a reparation to his eyes
and i said jesus i multiply myself in your gazes so that i too may have as many gazes for as many
times as you have gazed upon the creature with love i multiply myself in your tears so that i too
may cry for all the sins of creatures to be able to give you in the name of all gazes of divine love
and divine tears to give you complete glory and reparation for the gazes of all
then jesus wanted me to continue the reparations for his mouth his heart and his desires and so on
multiplying everything in his will so that it would be too long for me to say everything
so she moves forward and then jesus said my daughter as you were doing the acts in my will
many suns were formed between heaven and earth and i look at the earth through these suns
otherwise the earth would be so disgusting to me that i wouldn't be able to look at it
let's have a cook 113 lord your eyes are too pure to look upon sin but the earth receives little of
these suns he said because the darkness that they spread is such that as it comes up against these
suns they can receive neither all the light nor the heat so i want to give you sam 82 verse five
juteronomy 28 verse 29 and it's too dark to see john 9 40 to 41
afterwards jesus transported me into the midst of people but who can say what they were doing
i'll only say that my jesus with a sorrowful tone said this is very important for what we're
living today what disorder there is in the world now notice we start out with god's order and the
beauty and glory of everything that he has done now we look at the earth and the condition it's in
now and what disorder is there this disorder he said is because of the leaders both civilian
and ecclesiastical well if you go back to the scriptures and read the prophets you'll find that
every single one of the prophets blamed both the priests and the religious other religious
leaders and the civilian leaders for everything they were the shepherds and the sheep followed them
and so today we have to say where but where are the shepherds
they're self-interested and corrupted lives did not have the strength to correct their subjects
therefore they closed their eyes over the evils of the members since they already showed their own
evils and if they did correct them it was all in a superficial way because not having the life of
that good within themselves how could they infuse it into others you can only give what you have
so if you yourself are living a corrupted life you cannot give holiness to anybody else
if you yourself are living a completely selfish life how can you give any selflessness to others
how could they infuse it into others at how many times these perverted leaders have placed the evil
before the good to the point that the few good that's the remnant have remained shaken by this way
of acting of the leaders in other words the laity are scandalized therefore i will have the leaders
struck in a special way i want for that i want to give you a revelation 11 18 i will destroy the
destroyers of the earth but for the rest of the paragraph i want to give you isiah chapter
three and and isiah 22
verses 15 to 23 isiah 28 verses 1 to 15 and isiah 56 verses 10 to 12 just to give you an idea of
how the prophets dealt with the same thing but of course i could also give you Matthew 20
first of all Matthew 15 and its verses 1 to 10 where jesus gets at the leadership and then
the terrible judgment he gives them in Matthew 23 where he blames them completely for all that has
gone wrong and so luisa said jesus spared the leaders of your church they're very few
if you strike them the rulers will be lacking and jesus said don't you remember that i found
in my church on 12 12 apostles in the same way those few who will remain will be enough
to reform the world what he wants is people who can actually make a difference
the enemy is already at their doors the revolutions are already in the field
the nations will swim in blood so this is 1919 so he's looking forward to world war two
maybe world war three as well
the leaders will be dispersed pray pray and suffer so that the enemy may not have the freedom
to reduce everything to ruin so if you to reduce everything to ruin it means faith is destroyed
hope is destroyed love is destroyed therefore society falls into absolute chaos we're not too far
from that right now i'll take a break there and we'll take it up again